[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 12 avril
à la une aujourd'hui un projet vieux de
cinq ans les presque du quartier val
hibou a plaisir à vence les artistes ont
débuté leur travail il ya une dizaine de
jours et les premières couleurs
apparaissent sur les bâtiments de la
couleur c'est aussi l'une des ambitions
de maurepas la ville vient de lancer un
dispositif pour soutenir les commerces
de proximité objectif les aider à
financer les travaux de rénovation et
moderniser les devantures des magasins
dans ce journal également le break site
qui pourrait avoir des conséquences à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines certaines
entreprises craignent et prépare déjà la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne une sortie qui devrait être
actée dans deux ans normalement elles
sont le saut le symbole du renouveau
attendu du quartier attendu depuis cinq
ans les premières fresque du vally bout
ap les i après devis avec le début du
travail des artistes depuis une dizaine
de jours les couleurs apparaissent ainsi
sur les bâtiments d'ici 2020 le projet
prévoit la création en tout 2 8 fresque
géante dans ce quartier de 4000
habitants le point d'étape avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et osman un vendeur d
en 2016 200 habitants du quartier du
valais boue ont participé à des ateliers
de co-création le but
imaginez 8 fresque murale on les a
écoutés et dans cette oeuvre là la toute
première celle qui parle de la poésie
ils nous ont parlé d'un certain nombre
de mythes urbains d'expérience de
couleurs de cultures qui font leur
richesse
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a une grande
diversité de couleurs qui correspond
souvent à toute la diversité des
cultures qui font la richesse du valais
vous près de 50 cultures différentes
sont présentes sur le quartier et nous
sommes allés chercher aussi dans les
anecdotes de chaque culture pour parler
notamment de l'oiseau lyre qui est
l'oiseau de la poésie du moyen-orient et
un clin d'oeil aux fables de la fontaine
et depuis le début du mois d'avril la
première fresque murale prend forme ses
créations sont financés à hauteur de 170
euros par le bailleur les résidences
yvelines essonne
le quartier est réhabilité en trois
tranches on en est à la deuxième
il est donc ces résidences qui s'occupe
des travaux de réhabilitation du
quartier mais avec madame le maire nous
étions très intéressé pour reproduire ce
qu'on a vu dans d'autres villes comme à
lyon ou à chartres c'est à dire associer
les habitants à la construction de
fresques qui représente finalement leur
vie locale leur quartier leur immeuble
et qu'il raconte un petit peu leur
histoire est qu'il devienne fiers de
leur quartier
maintenant donc pleinement réhabilité le
bailleur devrait démarrer la
réhabilitation de la troisième tranche
de logements à la fin de l'année 2017
début 2018
au total huit presque seront visibles et
orneront les murs du quartier du valais
bout en 2020 et pour être complet sur le
sujet sachez que les trois premières
fresque seront à découvrir normalement à
la fin du mois de mai quatre pays la
france la suisse la belgique et le
canada une trentaine de joueurs sur une
patinoire le décor est planté
du 13 au 16 avril trappe accueille la
3ème édition du mondial de la prose
uniors durant quatre jours les équipes
vont s'affronter via des joutes verbales
et les participants sont actuellement en
pleine préparation mélanie poker a pu
rencontrer l'équipe québécoise
reportage
[Musique]
ils ont traversé l'atlantique l'équipe
canadienne est arrivée à trappes mardi
midi jeudi
il affronte la suisse dans leur premier
match d'impro dans ce mondial maintenant
qu'on a survécu à la viande à l'auto je
trouve que les stress paraît beaucoup
moins grave maintenant et ça devrait
bien se passer
c'est un peu de trac est sûr qu'il ya
toujours un peu arrivé ici pis elles
vont la plupart de postes par comprendre
qu'ils quittaient donc je dirais que
c'est le premier stress à a déjoué
mettant du 13 au 16 avril se déroule la
troisième édition du mondial de
l'improvisation celui des juniors
ils ont entre 15 et 19 ans il ya un truc
avec les juniors qu'on imagine pas c'est
qu'ils ne sont exclusivement que dans le
plaisir
c'est à dire que quel que soit le
résultat nous aurons partager un vrai
moment ils auront dit merci à la fin
c'est beaucoup plus facile de proposer à
des enfants et puis sur le spectacle je
vous invite vraiment à venir les voir
les juniors finalement ils n'ont pas
grand chose à envier alors à leur année
lundi l'équipe française faisait son
dernier entraînement
une équipe composée des meilleurs
trappistes sont bien sûr ça se passe
bien il ya toujours un bon esprit
d'équipé
c'est ça aussi qui fait qui fait notre
force c'est qu'on ait soulevé solidaire
on travaille comme il faut à
l'entraînement et
y a pas d'appréhension tout se passe
très bien pour l'instant c'est différent
parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout le même
style de jeu que nous a parlé belle on a
à peu près le même jeu mais les suisses
et des québécois on n'a pas du tout le
même style de jeu mais on arrive quand
même à comprendre ce qu'on improvise
quand même donc c'est ça qui nous
relient dimanche 16 janvier on connaîtra
le vainqueur de cette troisième édition
les québécois ont déjà deux trophées à
leur nom et si vous souhaitez encourager
les participants à ce mondial d'impro
rendez vous jusqu'à samedi à l'école de
musique et de danse de trappes dimanche
la finale elle aura lieu à la merise
attention la réservation est obligatoire
réservation en ligne via déclic théâtre
point canalblog.com on reste dans le
domaine culturel avec une artiste
peintre sculpteur et graveur teresa
gines année ce qui expose une
quarantaine de ses oeuvres actuellement
à guyancourt artiste local elle a
participé et remporté différents
concours de la ville les curieux peuvent
la découvrir son travail à la mezzanine
de l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au 6 mai on
écoute l'artiste à ce propos je me suis
inscrite à différents dans différents
ateliers de la région donc en at il et
gravures l'atelier sculpture en modèle
vivant
en aquarelle pour apprendre une
technique à la fois parce que j'ai
essayé de rattraper un petit peu tout ce
que j'avais pas fait pendant un certain
nombre d'années et j'avais envie un peu
d'experts d'expérimenter tout direction
maurepas à présent où la commune lance
un nouvel outil pour soutenir le
commerce de proximité une enveloppe de
15000 euros vient d'être voté pour
permettre notamment le financement de
travaux de rénovation des plus petits
commerçants
l'objectif est de les soutenir face à la
concurrence des grandes zones
commerciales notamment l les précisions
sur des images dans leur langue ils
fêteront l'an prochain leurs 30 ans
depuis 1988 manuela et son mari gère ce
commerce dans le centre ville de
maurepas un travail et une passion
développé au gré des crises économiques
et du développement des zones
commerciales aujourd'hui les espère
profiter du nouveau fonds lancé par la
commune pour rénover leurs devantures
il commence à voir quand on a des plis
qui sont un petit peu forte et un petit
peu d'infiltration donc envie ça fait
déjà deux trois ans que je voulais le
faire mais par des problèmes financiers
je ne le fais pas quand j'appris qui a
accès une première dans les yvelines
pourquoi pas donc je remplirai le
dossier si ça passe tant mieux ça peut
toujours aider
voté fin mars en conseil municipal le
fondeur doit permettre de soutenir les
commerces locaux dans la limite de trois
mille euros par dossier travaux de
rénovation d'embellissement ou encore de
sécurisation ce nouvel outil est une
première dans les yvelines donc sa
valise et soit resté ou soit à venir
justement dans des locaux vacants et
aussi dans le cadre d'une harmonisation
et d'une charte des enseignes parce
qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on a
des enseignes qui sont pas identiques en
fonction des commerces et donc on
travaille aussi la qualité esthétique
mais aussi la vétusté des vitrines donc
d'aider les commerçants dans cette
démarche pour bénéficier de l'aide
financière les commerçants maurepas
siens peuvent se rendre sur le site
internet de la ville ou directement en
mairie
les dossiers seront ensuite étudie par
une commission au total à quinze mille
euros sont débloqués par la commune
c'est une problématique que l'on
pourrait croire loin de saint quentin en
yvelines et pourtant deux semaines après
le déclenchement officiel de la
procédure pour le break site
certaines entreprises du territoire se
retrouvent concernés c'est le cas de la
filière française du groupe britannique
spir axe sarko elle est implantée à
trappes et pourrait subir les
conséquences de la sortie programmée du
royaume uni de l'union européenne elle
les précisions et les détails avec ce
reportage de nicolas d'andré séparateur
régulateur de température accessoires de
tuyauterie spire axe sarko propose des
outils qui permet d'utiliser la vapeur
comme produits énergétiques pour être
proche de paris et assurer son
développement
cette entreprise britannique est venu
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
en 1977
aujourd'hui les effets du bric sites
sont anticipés à la fois un sur le taux
de change qui effectivement peut jouer
beaucoup de par nos achats qui sont
quand même important d'angleterre et
deux sur les droits de douane et les
droits tout simplement d'accès au marché
européen
aujourd'hui les conséquences sont très
limitées demain nous verrons si
effectivement il y en avait les plus
importantes des conséquences connues
dans deux ans après les négociations
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni nous attendons effectivement michel
vergnier qu'il négocie au mieux les
intérêts européens dans le cadre de cet
essai d'accord à savoir notamment un
libre échange ou un quasi libre échange
effectivement des biens entre l'union
européenne
et le royaume uni afin de limiter
l'impact potentiel de ce pack site sur
l'activité d'une entreprise française à
travers son implantation mondiale les
risques immédiats pour le groupe
seraient limitées je pense que l'
influence de ce break site sur la vie de
la société française spie rail sarko
aura peu d'influencé
du côté de l'atelier plusieurs produits
achetés dans les filiales installées
dans tous les continents notamment au
royaume uni avec la chute du cours de la
livre depuis le vote du break site en
juin 2016 la filiale française bénéficie
d'une diminution des coûts aujourd'hui
le taux de change est favorable à la
france et donc nous achetons nos
produits avec un prix plus compétitif
vu la diversité de nos produits le
nombre d' usine que l'on a dans le monde
je ne suis pas inquiet l'entreprise peut
continuer à exporter sans se préoccuper
pour l'instant du changement des tarifs
douaniers dans l'attenté des résultats
des négociations
une actualité plus légère pour refermer
ce journal est pas qui approche à grands
pas dans quelques jours ce sera l'une
des fêtes les plus importantes du
christianisme
mais au delà de la proche religieuse
cette célébration s'est imposé pour
beaucoup comme une journée
incontournable pour manger du chocolat
les pâtisseries et du département se
prépare pour l'événement nous sommes
allés à la maison bigot situé à
versailles pour découvrir le travail des
équipes
camille lambert des oeufs des poules ou
des canards les cloches de pâques ont
déjà investi les pâtisseries
à quelques jours de la fête chrétienne
les chocolatiers sont à pied d'oeuvre
dans cette boulangerie pâtisserie de
versailles plus d'une tonne de chocolat
sera préparé pour l'occasion on est à
350 400 kg à peu près de christian paly
newey bon enfant en moyenne 40 50 kg
en après-midi quoi tous les jours on est
organisée le matin on fait la nuit on
travaille le matin ont fini nos de
fabriquer nos pâtisseries pour les
magasins et tout et après toute la
journée jusqu'au soir on fait du
chocolat ou en période de pâques
donc c'est grosse activité le labo 124
124 des classiques indémodables qui
représente ici 80 % des ventes de
chocolat à cette période les 20%
restants sont tenus par ses créations
une gisha un lapin ou une girafe plus
élaborés ces personnages nécessite un
travail minutieux presque de l'art nous
faisons une collection nous connaissions
une collection en série limitée se sont
pas des moulins s'est réalisée à base de
demi sphère et de petits de petits
moules à fait voilà nous fabriquons les
yeux les expressions nous donnons des
couleurs aussi ce qui fait le sujet
c'est surtout la couleur ce week end pas
de lyon ni d'hippopotames mais des veaux
et des poussins une mini ferme sera
installé devant la boutique pour fêter
pâques c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal
merci de nous avoir suivi tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver en replay
sur tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fils
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]